two of the most famous women in the
world one a Hollywood star recently
married into the British royal family
Megan Marco is the most radical thing to
happen to the royal family in decades
the other Home Counties born and bred
destined to be our future Queen
now sisters-in-law along with their
husbands they've been dubbed the Fab
Four and heralded as the future of the
monarchy do you ever have disagreements
about things but recently reports of a
royal rift between Megan and Kate have
hit the front pages Megan if she did
have a weak bridezilla moment she
wouldn't be the first bride to have
experienced that stories emerged of
drama at a bridesmaid dress fitting the
future Queen of England was in tears
over what megan has said to her so it's
Megan really the diva she's being
portrayed to be Megan is like I gotta go
go go go go go gotta get it all done no
I think she needs to chill and slow down
a little bit or is she suffering the
inevitable British media backlash and
other reports for fuse disguising where
the real tension lies I was told that
the rift was actually between William
and Harry and actually the problems were
between the brothers
as the Royals put on a Christmas show of
unity has the Queen had to intervene she
might say to her son Charles you're the
father-in-law not feds together please
are the Windsors still haunted by the
last American divorcee Wallis Simpson to
marry into the family or is the rumored
rift just a tabloid tale the media
contrary to popular belief do not make
up stories and when cake does become
queen will Megan be prepared to fall in
line Kate will always be in front this
is going to be alien to her having to
curtsy to her sister-in-law in public
Megan needs to understand this is the
British monarchy and she's not in a TV
show this is not a performance this is
the real story
you
[Music]
[Applause]